welcome to this video so wat cool so
weeks away co from Brazil and we have a
Tory attack weight quickly very quickly
gave me the bishop pal she does not
really have anything in particular as a
compensation mmm okay are you probably
it would probably play with you for so i
don't know if i should go bishop 2d6
maybe go here so that I have um Queen f4
Quincy seven as a possible route after
9024 this is the only active idea why it
has in this position I cannot he
couldn't even do that now just that i'll
think of it bsd for hangs wow he gives
me get another bishop I think the sky
hasn't doesn't really appreciate the
power of the bishops
yeah I know the position is relatively
closed at the moment but it's a it's a
simple fact that positions tend to open
up well they they really don't tend to
close up again after they've there
they've been opened once let's see yeah
maybe yes some some way cat taking
chances here Queen g3 or something I add
night age 67 others threat yeah I'm
going to open up the queenside don't
really don't really see any big attack
coming now I can consider to play h5
here maybe
John might have to looks very normal
yeah Brooke to be too if he goes rupee
one I have bishop g6 securing the B file
yeah yeah I expected something like that
he must get something going on the King
side of course if you just stay put some
it's it's a disaster okay let's see
should i should i do something like that
maybe Queen g6 queen age five it's
probably helpful
if he goes King edge to hear now this
one and now I have no I have Queen g6
with Queens off this is this is a really
really good check yeah I control the
beef are now rook be too yeah here you
just need some good technical play let's
hope I am I can manage that but take
rook h1 i don't i don't want to give him
any any kind of activity it's not
necessary yeah go here I am I've got
rugby too if he attacks it
ya know there's v5 breaking breaking up
the position right this must be good for
the the d6 bishop just take sake eight
not sure that this is the best but it's
good it's a good good line ok just drew
come q4 yeah i'm in a pin here this is a
pin
hmm maybe if I take your first and rook
c8 c3a this is also not not bad ok rock
to see 3 yes you will very quickly
played check
here and drew a three or something
better I can take a bishop before you
check this is a nice way to unpin check
now the night doesn't even ever square
designs can go to have to but then I
can't take a form as fun easy win yeah
he just just gave me the bishops for
nothing and this is really something you
should do it is closed but the position
will open up and he simply has no attack
here the Queen trade he really must
avoid the Queen trade at all costs I
mean I rather give up pawns then trade
queens IAM here this is just a win I
mean he will never ever try to be able
to consolidate this this is week I've
got the B file and tend the two the two
months so cm yeah I can take it but okay
it's it's just just easier that way not
to give him any counseling and here
maybe there was something more precise
but Luke see a droopy for is also strong
yeah but this is basically not
defensible check check check yeah yeah
you simply cannot cannot play like that
it's some Emily I even consider bishop
f6 to be questionable unless you
continue with afore you need to do
something quickly with your development
if you play it slow then black
equalizers easily and here even losing a
temple to give me it yet another bishop
it's some really very very cooperating
and yeah like black it's already better
here I'm quite surprised that I mean
it's only stockfish the engine here but
it only gives black 0.2 which is a joke
really this is already a very very very
very substantial advantage
like two bishops for nothing is worth
more than a porn in some positions okay
thanks for watching